ondeando el hillab esta joven iraní reta
al miedo y la violencia Estatal coreando
el lema mujer vida y Libertad
popularizado entre la clase media de la
República islámica contra las
imposiciones autoritarias del gobierno
islamista iraní mientras la indignación
por la muerte de maxam Mini siguen
aumento Naciones Unidas hizo un llamado
a las autoridades de Terán para
investigar lo sucedido
expressions
hacemos un llamado a las autoridades
para que respeten los derechos de las
mujeres y tomen medidas para eliminar
las formas de discriminación contra las
mujeres y las niñas se implementar
medidas efectivas para protegerlas de
otras violaciones de derechos humanos de
conformidad con Los estándares
Internacionales
Y es que el apoyo a las mujeres iraníes
se ha extendido desde Terán hasta otras
naciones de la región como Líbano o
Turquía pero también hasta Canadá
Bélgica Alemania e incluso Ecuador la
diáspora iraní las activistas en el
exilio uno en sus fuerzas para pedir el
apoyo internacional para aquellas
mujeres que sufren la tiranía y la
presión del estado iraní creo que esto
Solo es el principio durante 43 años el
pueblo de Irán ha estado oprimido y
ahora se está uniendo como nunca antes
por los derechos de las mujeres Este es
un momento histórico
estamos aquí para mostrar nuestra
solidaridad con las manifestantes de
Irán por la gente que siguen las calles
para combatir el régimen dictatorial
se trata de la oleada de manifestaciones
más importantes desde 2019 la diferencia
ahora es que son las mujeres jóvenes que
han perdido el miedo a salir a las
calles y reclamar por sus derechos